[Music]
a school reaching out to their kids and
community through the airwaves and
today's what's cool at school
these days of distance learning can feel
long and lonely
how does a school develop a culture
when the members of that community don't
actually meet
at the school woodbury middle school
wanted to reach out to isolated students
and find a way for them to still feel
connected to community
doing a school tv show would bring
everyone together
in the same time in the same place happy
monday longhorns
i communicate to the community in my
school
while not actually being there the
weekly broadcast is
anchored by students i'm really proud of
it the broadcast is wide-ranging from
basic announcements to contests and
trivia i'd like to introduce a new
segment we're calling longhorn
[Music]
don't trivia to know student awards
the counselors visited the homes of star
woodbury students
keep up the good work in your courses
you could be next
congrats to our students of the month
student needs and what you're going to
want to choose
is the counseling option on the main
menu
nevada history october 31st is when we
celebrate nevada becoming the 36th state
a joke of the week my favorite segment
is the joker of the week
because my friends when they see me do
it it brings joy to their faces
students even have a chance to introduce
their pets
[Music]
and there's a weekly challenge including
expressing what you're grateful for
here is this week's longhorns
challenge hello my name is royal
bernardez
and i'm grateful for my wonderful family
the kids are alone but during the
broadcast their school community speaks
and listens together
the best part is being able to represent
the school
and help bring things alive
them performing these it brings so much
joy
to my heart and that's what's cool at
school home edition
if you know something that's cool at
school during these days of distance
learning let us know about it
send us an email cool at school at eight
newsnow dot com